vielleicht habt ihr schon mal eines
diese videos gesehen
das ist eine visualisierung von dem was
an einem klavier gespielt wird und sieht
so ein bisschen aus wie guitar hero es
gibt aber für jedes lied eines dieser
tutorial ist in dem man glasklar sieht
was und wie man spielen muss ohne dafür
noten lesen können zu müssen man kann
sich jetzt also hier einfach so die
these dass man die zum beispiel
anschauen und nachspielen kann ich jetzt
einfach so ohne es gilt jedes lied
spielen lernen und wenn ja wie schnell
diese woche lernt klavier oder versuchst
du mindestens um möglichst gut klavier
zu lernen sollte ich mir wahrscheinlich
ein klavierlehrer zulegen aber um in
möglichst kurzer zeit maximal vier
klavier in maximal wenig gehirn zu
bringen wenn ich keine noten lernen
keine techniken und und ich konnte mich
aus absolut notwendigste mein ziel ist
es zwei lieder zu lernen cantina band
aus star wars
und die titelmusik von intercell
auf geht's
[Musik]
damit das nicht so bleibt fange ich
jetzt mal lieber direkt an
geschwindigkeit 0,25
[Musik]
anfangs tut natürlich mit der melodie
hand mit der rechten hier und nicht mit
linken die kommt später und dann
versuche ich die rhythmisch
zusammenzuführen
[Musik]
cantina band ja noch langsam richtig
langsam so langsam darfst dich langweilt
ist es nicht langsam wie soll ich denn
das angriffsverhalten schau mal das wenn
du spielst desto hier in dem handgelenk
locker will es nicht verkrampft sich
dagegen
wir greifen da ein bisschen über
versuchen wir denn mit der vier
anzufangen
also entweder zwei einzufangen und damit
dafür dass die fünf dann zehn fingern
12345 so noch mal ganz langsam hier
[Musik]
beck passt lässt thomas epp haltung
bewahren
ich habe keinen platz gemacht hat sich
ethisch in alta badia schon fast
halbwegs ich muss noch mehr üben ich
weiß ihr habt recht aber ich habe auch
nicht stunde dafür gebraucht obwohl das
jetzt nur so ein bisschen den anfang
davon klimpern kann schon krass also
wenn man mal bedenkt dass mein entziehen
hier das ist
dann muss ich mich auf jeden fall noch
ordentlich reinhängen guten morgen mal
schauen was über nacht geblieben ist ich
war langsamer an
[Musik]
geht doch heller ich muss aber sagen
handgelenk tut mir jetzt schon richtig
weh ich glaube ich bin bereit zeigt den
rest des videos zu wehren kann nämlich
ganze zeit und sie spielen weil die wird
nämlich echt schnell alt ganz kurz die
noch weiter gehts mit der zweiten
wie soll ich denn das gleicht hinkriegen
ein a2 ja
[Musik]
das wird ein schwieriges unterfangen
kann man sich merken erklärt was das
hier
[Musik]
adscale zu spielen wird so schwierig ist
dass man das wirklich hört und jetzt
deswegen mitten in der nacht liegen hier
auf werke aber
[Musik]
es ist zu sehr maße schwierig diese
zweiter hand gleichzeitig zu spielen
[Musik]
ich habe heute das sei die fortschritte
erziele dabei ich hoffe dass wichtig
konzepte und die prinzipien und dieses
die auffassung zwei handy zu spielen und
mich auf zwei sachen gleichzeitig ist
ein bisschen zu konzentrieren dieses
wissens mitnehmen kann um den zweiten
song ganz schneller zu lernen aber dafür
muss ich selbst mit dem song fertig
lernen dass wir noch ein gutes stück
arbeit
[Musik]
ich kann es auch nicht komplett flüssig
spielen aber an und für sich haben jetzt
zumindest den ganzen inhalt des liedes
im kopf und darauf freue ich mich jetzt
schon so krass weil es ist einfach
wisst ihr eigentlich langsam und jetzt
geht's an das worauf ich mich schon die
ganze zeit freue und zwar interstellar
gut probleme das macht
sollten das spielen wo sind der joh
caracas es ist home kassakurs
plötzlich episch normal üblich normal
[Musik]
für sich unfassbar frischen dann mal was
schönes und bedeutungsvoller zu spielen
anstatt immer nur tag für tag fünf tag 6
morgen ist das finale wie viel habe ich
bisher geschafft wir fangen an mit der
guten cantina band langsamer
[Musik]
ganz und an der kasse bat
muss ich noch einiges üben bis das
halbwegs sitzt wie sieht es mit der
stille
[Musik]
und dann jetzt das monster
ein bisschen unterschätzt habe ich das
vielleicht schon ich habe noch viel vor
8 stunden klägliches scheitern später
[Musik]
es fühlt sich echt mega kasachen
es ist so ein unglaubliches gefühl dass
einfach diese musik aus mir raus kommt
aber ich habe mir zu viel vorgenommen
die kompletten fünf minuten von
untersteller in der woche fehlerfrei zu
lernen s too much
ich muss mich wohl doch nur auf cantina
band konzentrieren
sie war einen tick tock geschickt in
denen jemand erklärt wie man die musik
von avatar der herr der elemente
gespielt was übrigens die beste serie
überhaupt ist und die filmmusik die weg
jedes mal so viele erinnerungen dass ich
fast beiden könnte ich geb den letzten
versuch und es ist viel leichter aus als
inception oder vielleicht doch einen
zweiten song hin
[Musik]
okay das ist man ja viel aufwendiger als
ich dachte ich habe einen tag zahlen
let's go was heißt das war mal wieder
die hobby dosis aktionäre ich bin weit
davon entfernt 100% flüssig zu spielen
meine technik ist grauenvoll und ich
kann die lieder nicht mal ganz aber ihr
hin haben mich sieben tage kopf gegen
die wand klavier lernen gebracht
[Musik]
der hat sich ja also ich das einfach
kann die herzen
[Musik]
b
am ende ist es für die wirklich sehr
kontinent habe ich mir diese viel
gewollt
ich denke ich jetzt her
das ist ja gar kein text wartet ab
[Musik]
heute wissen die cantina welt wenn ihr
mich gesammelt habt ruft er vereint
[Musik]
[Gelächter]
das war nicht mal ein richtig spaß
experimentell auf jeden fall am ball
bleiben weil das muss ich auch e mails
seien um halbwegs gut zu werden wie
überall dauert sie nicht auch hier jahre
um irgendwas richtig zu beherrschen wenn
jetzt zu wissen möchte welches video als
nächstes kommen schaut gerne wenn wir
auf installieren vorbei da passt sich
immer ausschnitte aus der neuen wohnung
aber auch schon aus meinen nächsten
experimenten und wenn er mich auf dieser
reise begleiten möchte dann folgt mir
gern auf diesem kanal und dann sehen was
mir macht's gut